so nice and that is this job really
everybody wants
we have many guests here today we have
students from the school from all
disciplines we have people from lifelong
learning
we have guests from the community we
have faculty staff and so we have a
broad range of people to to include in
this conversation grow I just ask a few
questions first and will lead to a
discussion and then hopefully you can
join us for questions about your job it
seems so odd to me that you can watch
that film and know that you're a son of
Pittsburgh that you lived in Pittsburgh
went to school in Pittsburgh came to CMU
and this extraordinary unbelievable
career has enveloped you had you any
thought it was possible what brought you
to Pittsburgh what brought you to
Carnegie take at that time and what were
your hopes and aspirations right at the
beginning you know it's I had no sense
that I'd end up in film for sure that's
for sure none and that just happened
very organically I mean I really you
know I started in the chorus I mean it's
that classic you know trajectory because
I didn't have a sense of that I you know
I Pittsburgh is an amazing place to grow
up for me because my parents are
spectacular people and they they showed
me so much and opened my eyes to so much
that was happening in Pittsburgh at the
time you know there's the Pittsburgh
opera the Pittsburgh Ballet the Public
Theater Pittsburgh civic Light Opera
which was huge for me
then of course there was you know the
arts everywhere here and I just was
exposed to so much that I felt it was
like a mini New York in a way I guess
and I felt
know that every anything was possible
and I started at the Pittsburgh civic
Light Opera when I was a kid I was in
The Sound of Music there and the King
and I and and musicals I guess maybe it
was because of my parents loved musicals
I don't know if it was that or what it
was specifically but I you know I wanted
to be a dancer and a singer and an actor
and and the music theater program here
at Carnegie Mellon was in its third year
and back in 1906 oh my god Holly Hunter
is two years older than me though that's
my favorite part she was a junior when I
was a freshman but you know it was an
incredible program because there were no
set there was no such thing anywhere
else really in the country
Boston University had a great theater
program NYU but you know and and I
auditioned for all those places but it
was here that there was there was a
music theater which is what I wanted to
do and I wanted to dance and when you're
young it's like an athlete you want it
that's when you you want to dance then
my spies in the Faculty told me that you
were a very devoted focused driven
student did you feel that that was the
case in 1980 well I felt I took
advantage of what was here let's put it
that way I really felt I wanted to do it
and so much so that I actually in my
junior year audition for the show a
chorus line and I and I got the show and
I left
Carnegie for a year and did a chorus
line on the road Michael Bennett hired
me and I did that show and then came
back from my senior year and it was nice
because I could join my classic and they
gave me credit for the full year which
is great straight A's or something I
remember opening the I remember opening
my report card or something and I was
like you know in San Francisco lounging
in my apartment I thought oh that's nice
I got
I didn't even do it but it was it was
but I learned more in an odd way my
senior year after having been out in the
professional world and coming back and
saw what I what I needed to work on what
I needed to focus on and I really took
advantage of Carnegie that year very
much so so are you saying the value of
an internship somewhere in your late
junior years just before your senior
year that that was a turning point for
you that you thought the profession the
world what's out there what possibly yes
well I was ready in a way because as a
dancer it's like I said like being an
athlete I was you know I was 19 but you
know I was really ready to dance at my
sort of the height of your career in a
way is your late teens early 20s as a
dancer you know
and so I I was excited to to get out
there and do it and I really learned
what it was what that was like
you know at the height to a chorus line
was sort of at that point was the show
to get it would be like getting I don't
know Book of Mormons now or something I
don't know if you want to be in that
show I mean there's a show like you know
it was the hot show it was the show what
did you have you and I are about the
same size about the same
I had a six o'clock kick I don't know
what did I have Barbara I don't know
that was it I'll tell you something I
always loved when I would audition as a
dancer and you'd walk in with you know
hundreds of kids but I if you get past
that and I would get to the singing part
of it and I could sing and that was very
rare for dancers you know and then and
then I would get to the reading and I
could act because I'd come you know I I
had training so I I could put it all
together and so I might you know I I my
first Broadway show was Zorba with
Anthony Quinn and and that's where I met
Graziella Danielle who was this
incredible director choreographer she
choreographed Zorba and she asked me to
do the next show that she was doing
called the rink which starred Liza
Minnelli and Chita Rivera and I was the
dance captain I was 23 years old and I
was the dance captain of the show and
that's when I started to learn what it
was like to be on the other side of the
table and you know and get a sense of
how you put together a show and and you
know and a dance captain you know when
the director and choreographer leave you
sort of take over the show and so I'm 23
years old knocking on Liza Minelli's
dress remember saying giving her notes
for the performance that she had just
you know I mean you know picking her up
off the floor and then giving her the
notes now she was but I have to tell you
in that show Chita Rivera I don't know
if you know cheetah
she just work is that Judy there
Chita Rivera is you know is our patron
saint of musical theater and she taught
me so much about discipline and how you
work in the theater and how you respect
it yes what I've seen lots of theater
schools and I think what makes this a
very interesting school is that the
quality of the acting across the whole
school whether you're doing music
theater are you doing acting is awfully
important to both yes it's all the same
I mean you know when you're going out to
do you're in a musical Europe playing a
character it's not a dance concert it's
not a
you know it's you're not at an opera
where you're just a concert where you're
singing it's you're playing a role so
that was always important and and that's
what's so great about Music Theatre is
that you can sing and dance and play a
character at the same time and I learned
I learned how to do that here
so when you have a film like Caribbean
where you've got Geoffrey Rush a theatre
actor yes and you've got Johnny Depp
he really wants to do it like that yes
your theater experience gives you that
double world to help them both yes well
I you know the theater discipline and
how that works helps you everywhere
because it's sort of like the real thing
film is is it's very interesting because
there are people from theatres like a
Geoffrey Rush and there's somebody like
Johnny Depp who's never done theatre in
his life and doesn't know that how that
works and he's not he doesn't really
like to rehearse and Geoffrey likes to
rehearse I like to rehearse because it
helps me know where things are but I'll
never forget the first film I did
Chicago I was doing a scene with Richard
Gere and Renee Zellweger and it was a
very intense scene and emotional and and
I and I wanted to rehearse it because I
wanted to decide where the camera was
gonna go and I said okay so here we go
let's let's work on it and then Renee
was kind of marking it and I said I said
well can we let's do it and then she
said to me something that just rings am
i here she said let's not squeeze the
lemons she said and I didn't understand
what that meant
nobody's talking about it I don't see
any lemons here you know I didn't
understand what she was talking about
and then I realized oh I see note what
she means is she said she's from she's a
film actress she didn't go she's not
from theater she wanted to wait to
capture that emotion and in the moment
when we were filming in that moment so
that was something I learned and it was
and I and so I worked with people
differently Daniel day-lewis is
obviously one of our greatest actors and
when I did nine with him there was a he
likes to live the role I think you know
these things I mean I know he just
finished doing Abe Lincoln and he lived
without electricity and to God while he
was shooting and it was similar on our
movie he was playing Guido Contini which
is a Italian film director and he had us
recreate an entire Italian office from
the 60s in his dressing room and he
would be in that and everything was
exactly as it would be in the 60s and he
lived that way and he spoke that way
people thought you know some people
think his process is creepy and I
actually thought it was great because
film is tricky you're constantly waiting
waiting to get you know your lighting
and waiting and waiting and waiting and
then you've got to put it out there when
when it's time because time is money so
he stays in character in his so that
when he goes there it feels very natural
but this example is of how heat works we
were doing a scene where it was a press
conference and he said I don't want to
rehearse this so I rehearsed it without
him with all the reporters and all the
actors playing the reporters and and
then I called action and he came in and
he didn't know where were the next
question was coming from he didn't he
played it as the character and knew the
lines but it was all very real for him
and that's his process and I don't mind
changing my process for their process
they're the ones that are that are up
there when we look at that show real
that the variety and the aesthetic of
the films is so different they're so
challenging they're so wonderfully wild
what are the Givens for you when you
make a choice on a project you are given
X number of scripts they come through
your
what what makes that moment that says
yep this one's for me I have I have to
have not have done it before because I
have no interest in making the film
again you know it's something it has to
be something that's fresh and new and
scary when I did memos of a Geisha I
directed that film through interpreters
because the entire cast was speaking
English for the first time so I had
Japanese and Chinese interpreters on the
set and that's how I work with it and
that was this huge mountain to climb but
I loved it because it was so so
challenging and and 9:00 was this
bizarre small musical in a way that was
interested me because of the Fellini
aspect and I thought it translated
you know when I'm looking to do a
musical it has to make sense to me on
film as a musical why are they singing
it has to and it pretty much took place
in his mind so that was thrilling to
work on and and pirates I had never done
an action-adventure movie I'd never done
a 3d film that's for sure and I and so
is this huge learning experience because
it's your life you know it's not just
your game you know this is your life
experience movies for directors take two
to three years it's just the truth
actors come in for a couple of months
but you're there prepping it and then
you film it and then you edit it and
then you release it and then you promote
it and it's two and a half three years
sometimes yeah so that it has to be
something you're you love and you're you
and and also you get that moment you
don't want anybody else to do it like I
want to do this one you know we're at
the stage of the year where a lot of our
young actors have been in New York and
they're looking at agents they're
looking at managers we're about to go
out to LA we're about to audition for
actors and managers you see now the top
talent in the world you have the choice
of every single person in the world to
choose what are the qualities if what
dinner that young actor sitting there
stepped up on stage now what are you
looking for what's the quality that says
that girl
as something that I'm interested in it's
you it's it's unique it's being unique I
mean that's what I look for something
that's you that you're yourself because
we're all different and we have to
celebrate those differences that's the
most important thing not be afraid of
those differences trying to fit in to
something and be somebody just here
that's who you are and that's what you
can bring this different than that
person there it's just who you are and
that's not it's not something you know
it's something that continues to grow I
mean it's not something like this is Who
I am
you continue to find who you are I mean
that's I think college is a lot about
finding out who you are I mean I there
are times you this is the best time to
say you know are you Laurie or u8o Annie
are you will Parker are you curly you
don't I mean I know you try and figure
out what roles feel right for you and
and you try on different things that's
why it's good to just try everything you
know when you're doing when you're when
you're in school but that's what I'm
looking for I'm looking for someone who
brings their own point of view something
from themselves it's funny I'm looking
to cast right now opposite Johnny Depp
in the Thin Man an actress and it's the
Thin Man is a movie from the 30s that
started William Powell and Myrna Loy and
it was a they they did six of six movies
and what's incredible about that film
those films is that their chemistry and
she had a Myrna Loy had a style and she
was funny and and and beautiful and and
and I'm looking to cast that now and
it's it's it's not easy to find someone
who has their own stamp their own thing
you know stead of like generic generic
movie star girl that's not interesting
to me what make me the great audition
for you well I think you have to think
of it as a performance I don't think you
can go in thinking they have it because
I have a good imagination but most of
the
to say the stupid people sitting next to
me but I don't mean that I mean like the
pretend like the producers and the money
people or whatever they don't have a
great imagination so you actually have
to kind of come in and and and and play
the role and I like when people come in
and are serious to do that you know and
come in and do in it's a performance
it's not just like something almost
gonna do a you know the people I know
who have done really really well with
the people that are committed and work
hard in that way right prepare what's a
great collaborator for you what what
either as an actor is a temperamental
actor or talented actor it doesn't
necessarily matter what is the great
collaborator them across the boards for
me it's you have to check your ego at
the door that's it you cannot come in
with ego that I I will I think I maybe
work with one or two people in my whole
career who I've not liked because they
bring their ego in and it doesn't work
and I'm talking about
on every level as designers
cinematographer whatever it's not about
you it's about serving the piece that's
what it's about it's about serving that
and we're all doing the same thing we're
all finding our way it's not done it's
being created in that moment and you
have to play and feel free to try things
and not be judged I mean I try and
create an atmosphere of positive
reinforcement with no judging because
you learn so much from the mistakes you
make but to try I mean I've worked with
so many actors that are new to musicals
for instance Daniel day-lewis never sang
before Renee Zellweger never sang before
you know these people who are new to
musicals and don't know how it's done
and I just try and give them a great
sense of freedom and and and care and
support and and and a feeling that they
can do it you know not like it's
something you know and that's the only
way I know how to work and it has to be
everybody in that room has to have
checked that ego because I couldn't yeah
what if there's any of that it's that's
the thing I just don't tolerate that so
now tell me what's the first meeting
like with so so
how does that happen because there must
be overwhelming mirth on the other side
as well that's when I felt like a kid
from Pittsburgh mmm
you know she uh it was a very that when
I met her it was right out of a movie I
was rehearsing in a soundstage
in Los Angeles in Hollywood and the
doors I heard she was here and the doors
swung open and she walks and so all I
saw I mean this is a hand to God all I
saw was a silhouette first you know
which is still like that you know so
beautiful and she walked in and she had
those beautiful eyes this incredible
cat-like eyes and that beautiful foot I
mean the most beautiful woman ever on
film I think most beautiful Phillips
that incredible strong no she was very
tall and I didn't expect that I thought
she was gonna be smaller she's very very
tall and she took my hand and said you
know ciao and her so I don't know it's
something you know and I just it was it
you realize that movie stars of that
time it was about an aura you know and
then of course you it takes a long time
to get over that it's a fuel around that
kind of thing takes a while it happened
when I work with Julie Andrews it
happened when I work with Liza
originally it just takes a while but
then after then you realize they're just
people and and they're scared and
they're nervous and and excited to work
and and I remember I was sitting with
her one set the the SAG Awards the
ensemble of nine was nominated for Best
ensemble in a film and so we were all
there together and I was sitting next to
Sophia and she said to me I can't
believe I'm here with all these all
these major people and I said all these
major people can't believe they're here
with you and she did and she says I'm
just a little girl from Napoli and
that's how she thinks of herself you
know so it's it's a beautiful thing to
find out who these people really are
sitting the other night there was a big
more life it felt like a memorial but it
it was the back I had died
even if the fundraiser for the
roundabout in New York and I was sitting
near rob and it was Richard Gere and
Julie Andrews and all these
extraordinary people sitting all very
close together all looking at you and
every single person I think that got up
to speak said how humbled you were or
what a wonderful collaborator you were
or what an easy job you made it for them
to work now how does that happen when
you have a film director is arguably the
most important person in the world after
Obama you have everything at your
fingertips now you are making a 250
million dollar film how do you remain
this gentle calm cool that's such a
lovely thing to ask I you know I have to
say that I was the first time I ever
said action and cut was a television
movie of Annie in the 90s late 90s and
there was a director that came to visit
me on the set the first day and I
remember he's standing there and he was
I had worked with him in a as a
choreographer in a television version of
Cinderella with Whitney Houston and and
he was horrible director he was mean he
made people cry it was a hateful
experience I watched it all unfold and I
couldn't believe that he was creating
this experience for these people and he
can and he was there the first day I
walked in to shoot this movie and I
thought what is he doing here and then
he came over to me so I'm here to give
you advice
and so he said just remember everyone is
here to serve you to be said everyone's
here to serve you and your vision and
needle walked away and I thought clearly
but and I and I and I and I I knew it
was the exact opposite yeah that I was
there to serve everybody that's what I
wanted to do and that's what I've always
done I'm there to serve people and and
and make them feel great and have a
incredible experience because that's
when the best work gets done right for
me just before we go to some questions
feel your visual aesthetic is so
astounding where does it come from and
what informs that everyday and how do
you make sure it's topped up every day
and how do you make sure you're at the
cutting edge of what the visual world in
which we live now is it's interesting
you know I had a great friend who passed
away another film director named Anthony
Minghella who was an extraordinary man
who taught me so much we collaborated on
a couple projects together he wrote them
and he was an amazing man and he said to
me once you know a film director you're
hired for your taste that's all we can
bring
your taste your you're at your
Sensibility
and I and that comes from who you are
and what you love and what you watch and
and and what inspires you what inspired
you as a kid you know I was so lucky
because I grew up going to the
incredible productions by Michael
Bennett Bob Fosse Gower champion Tommy
tune those are the those are my heroes
on stage and on film Stanley Donen
Robert Wise Vincente Minnelli George
Cukor those were my heroes and so I you
know they brought me so much and I try
to obviously stay open to what the world
is today but it really is just comes
from what you love you go to galleries
you can do
oh yes all the time luckily you know
with you travel when you're doing film
even at the end of the experience you
know for instance of pirates we were all
over the world promoting the film and so
there's always time for that you know
you're a yeren you're in Madrid or
you're in Russia you know we played it
can this year out of competition and it
was like the cannot he's putting on
their 3d glasses was hilarious but it
was great but we you know we so I've
been lucky enough to be live and work
all over the world and and that's
inspires me of course and the unique
relationship with your sister Kathleen
how how has that informed your work and
your life and just the way you go about
your work I'm so lucky to have a sister
who's also in the business because you
know there's not many people you can
trust in your life and in a way you try
to and you and but you know you can
trust your sister and she for instance
she just she's opening a show next month
new Broadway musical called nice work if
you can get it starring Matthew
Broderick and Kelly O'Hara and she and I
just went to her run through the other
day right and watched her run through
and you know and then and I can talk to
her the way nobody can talk to her you
know give us some notes well you know
well she oh I would never unless she
asked and she asks you know what do you
you know tell me I need because here's
the thing and this is very true of
anything you do but I find it very very
true a film I wish I could see my own
film it's so hard to see it fresh you
you know it's it's one of the hardest
things you put it together every single
second of it it's like a mosaic every
piece of it you know every bit of it
every piece of the score every color
correction every sound edit everything
and the hardest thing to do is just to
walk in as an audience member and watch
it and have a sense of what's working
what's not it's
do you have K people you go to to get a
very good reaction or an honest reaction
I like I like to see I like to sitting
in an audience you know when you take it
to and more than anything I learned more
from an audience coughing or removing a
rat no or getting up you know that kind
of stuff
but I that's what you learn and not any
you get a real sense of it which is good
wonderful
shall we open it up to some questions
does somebody have a question for Rob if
you'd like if you'd please come to the
microphone which is just down on the
landing where you're from or who you are
that would be very very helpful so here
we have Adrian hi I'm Adrian Ensco I'm
from upstate New York and thank you so
much for coming and giving us your
advice oh please so throat thank you
back
I was wondering because I I'm interested
in a lot of things in the theater as a
performer as a collaborator and possibly
as a director how did you make that
transition between being an actor and
dancer and singer into directing it was
very it was very organic for me and
something I didn't quite plan in an odd
way but you know I started as a dance
captain and then an assistant
choreographer and then I injured I was
doing the show cats on Broadway and I
injured myself in cats and and so
someone asked me to choreograph a
production of the rink which I had been
on Broadway but down in Florida a
regional theatre I'd never choreographed
before and so I that job and then I got
another job choreographing and then
another job directing and choreographing
and sort of worked my way up to Broadway
and when you get in that Club you know
you get the first that there was a I
knew cheetah
and there was a kiss of the Spider Woman
was playing in Canada they were it was
it was Canada in London then Broadway
and this was how Prince and Kander and
ebb and you know Terrance McNally this
incredible team and the choreographer
wasn't working out and so cheetah and
John and Fred who I knew very well
brought me in and I reek Oriya graft the
show so then I was the choreographer of
that show and then I started
choreographing on Broadway show show and
then went and then I was asked to direct
and choreograph sort of the natural
progression after you've choreographed a
few shows to direct and choreograph on
Broadway and and then you sort of start
all over again in the film world someone
asked me to choreograph a television
musical an original television musical
that Jerry Herman wrote for Angela
Lansbury that and then choreographed
some television and then directed that
Annie that I said I remember they said
to me you know you're we'd like you to
direct a musical for television I was so
excited and I said and it's Annie and I
was like oh but then I thought okay you
know what
I got to think of this in a different
way that's it you know and I guessed and
I cast you know Audra McDonald and
Victor Garber and and Alan and
Kristin Chenoweth and had a real theater
cast and a dead dog and a great dog and
did it didn't my it did my version of
Annie and so then and that meant led to
film okay Cathy
hi I'm Jessie Shelton I'm originally
from Minneapolis Minnesota I was
wondering you mentioned that pirates was
your first 3d film as well as being your
first action film and I just wondered
because 3ds really picking up these days
what was that like what's different when
you're directing a 3d film versus well
first of all you're using two cameras
because you it's a right eye and a left
eye I mean that's we see in 3d so that's
what happens so you're so this is twice
the problem you know and it's a very
interesting thing because you have to
a real quick quick quick lesson about it
as you know our eyes are about
two-and-a-half inches apart and so the
cameras you can't get them that close so
they actually there was one on top and
one on the bottom or one on one here or
one it's sometimes like that but these
these interesting rigs and you have to
decide with each shot how much depth and
that's all about like no depth is to D
and then you widen it to two and a half
you don't go any wider than that for
each shot you know in close-ups you just
tighter you know small or smaller range
and then you do depth the bigger depth
for the for the wide shots and and we
were it was interesting because we were
the first film ever to take 3d on
location they had never done that before
it was always done on stages and we were
guinea pigs I guess that went into
jungles and caves and cliffs and ships
and it was insane but it was we learned
as we went the cameras have gotten
smaller each time you just have to
they're delicate so you so it you know
it takes twice the amount of time to
load the film and if one goes down I
mean I have a great performance and
they'd say one I went down you know
let's just make this movie forget it
but then you have to do it again so
there's that you know you see you're
like it's like it must have been what it
was like when they started sound you
film you started you know whole new
thing do you map out when the arrows
come at you and when the moments
definitely but you can do a lot of that
all most of that stunts in
post-production you can decide how far
something comes out into the audience
it's called convergence and you decide
how much you want that to come out into
the audience and how much you want it to
go into the screen I didn't want to do
that many trick things because it's like
I don't know Shrek 4d at Universal
Studios I couldn't do that okay we have
another question hi my name is Megan
spats and I'm originally from Alaska all
of your films have such a cohesive
design to them in terms
the production design the costume design
and the cinematography could you talk a
little bit about your process with the
production staff and the cinematographer
and that's such a lovely question you
know I think it's all comes from theater
for me because I pulled everybody
together early on and it's everybody's
at the meetings in other words the first
time I was having a set meeting
production design meeting I invited the
cinematographer and the costume designer
as well and and and they were
everybody's like why are we going to
this meeting because it's a production
design meeting I said because it's all
it's all the same thing to me and I
think that's unusual probably coming
from theater I didn't know any other way
to do it everybody works together to
create the vision because I think it
affects you know I mean that's how it
works it's not really a something that
happens much in film but I like to do
that and maybe that's why you know I
like we're all in the same page as we're
moving forward hi I'm Nina I'm Eunice
nice to meet you I'm from Chicago and
I'm a junior in high school and I am
here visiting today
and I wanted to know how you grew as an
actor as a dancer as a singer as a
performer through the program here and
would you have gotten this experience
anywhere else well for me it was all
because it was all here at and you know
at and we were sort of learning how it
was gonna all work together to you know
wasn't as cohesive as it is now it was
sort of departmental and you know you go
the music building and you go to the you
know it was sort of but because it was
all happening at once it was perfect for
me especially the acting program which
is so strong and I think it was it was
the fact that I was I could I could do
it and and be doing ballet one minute
and then you know acting one next
Voice sofa sofa or something like that
banette it was this wonderful
combination of things that that I
couldn't find any I couldn't find
anywhere else and at this level so it
was it was really perfect another
question hi I'm Elizabeth I'm originally
from the DC area you touched a little
bit on the influence of theater in the
television and film world and I was
wondering if you could speak a little
bit about the relationship moving back
and forth between the directing theaters
and film and what how they influence
each other as well as like how film
influences your stage direction the
first time I ever worked on film was
choreographing this musical for ferengi
Lansbury and I I remember I was
choreographing this big number and I and
I thought okay well we'll do that and
then we'll transition you know we have
to create a transition to get to there
and then the director said to me or you
could just cut it's like what oh I see
that and I was so naive and I that I
loved it immediately because we'll just
cut to that and cuts of that and you
know is all that all of a sudden you
know but that's the hardest part I mean
I think you really you know when you're
working on stage it's all about
transitioning into the next thing and
how you get the dancers off and get the
star back on and bring on the set and
what's happening that's our so you know
New York sitting there waiting for the
set to change and it's all about
transitions and I found on film there
was such freedom I didn't have a front I
didn't ever proscenium I could shoot
from behind you know I had all the so in
an odd way out what I found myself
having to do was actually create
boundaries for myself when I was doing
when I do film because it's limitless so
you actually have to kind of create your
own sort of shape you know my name's
Mitch I'm from Florida it's a similar
question could you talk about your
philosophy on the function
of dance in a stage production versus
how you feel it applies into a movement
hmm it's interesting I feel that there
that dance on film is will always be a
hybrid of theater and film it because
you know to me some of the greatest
numbers I mean the greatest numbers that
I can think of and dance are always in
musicals that are actually on a stage
that's you know cabaret you know or you
I think of the bandwagon or they were
out of town with the show and they would
do a big number on stage and then they
pull back and you know this crazy number
then everybody be applauding like it was
all done on a stage and but but there's
a there's a sense that it's there's a
there's a world that it shares and so
it's and which makes sense because it's
it's that kind of that kind of that kind
of discipline and I think that that's
informed me I think coming from and you
have to rehearse so coming from stage
has helped me make that transition to
film because I think of it first in that
way what about the physicality of actors
on film we often you're here yes but you
know that Jeffrey Russia you know that
somebody like Johnny Depp's got this
wonderful ability how do you get them to
bring it up through their face through
their eyes through their through their
kid well I you know it's interesting I
you know you do different setups so you
do the wide shot or the cowboy shot
which is holster is an app you know
that's what they call that a cowboy or a
way shot or you do a close-up and you
usually it depends that how you do it
sometimes an actress will say to me
something like can we do the close-up
work first because I feel ready
emotionally to do that and then do
because that's when you need the great
performance or some people like to build
to it you know slowly and so that's been
interesting but I find that I like to
cover scenes as much as I can so that
there's there's an opportunity to get
because sometimes you get something
physically from someone like a Johnny
Depp or a Geoffrey Rush that you really
need to have and then there'll be the
moment but they know you know when
you're coming in close you've got a it's
it's got to be truth
watching the produce event is I don't
think it's very funny at the end well
let me think well I mean here's the
thing with with with with film it's it's
fantastic because it's an ongoing
process your editing is your is your
final rewrite you know you're in the
room it's the best part of the whole
process because you're just in a room
with one guy or one woman and you're
sitting there and and you can try
different things and you can try cutting
out this line or adding a line and you
can try that all that kind of thing so
you have the opportunity to make
adjustments I remember Chicago didn't
end quite that way they end singing all
that jazz and then bump it's over and I
they had finished the song and then they
were they were it became sort of a kind
of crazy chaotic mess of adoration from
the fans back and forth and musically it
didn't work because it was like we'd
finished the song and then there was
this other kind of thing that just sort
of sat there and so I needed to I needed
to put the song I needed to tie it all
together and I was able to do that in
the editing room yeah you know I just
moved some things around and tried
different things and so it could end
with them singing all that jazz I think
yeah hi I'm from the Philadelphia area
so you mentioned that like you want to
do things that you haven't done before
and that in a sense I think you said
that scared you or that you know gave
you a little bit of that so that kind of
opens up a daunting field and so I was
wondering how do you pick what
specifically to do next because I mean
it sounds like even though you've done
so many things there's obviously so many
laughs yes well it's interesting I mean
I just had a meeting actually a Warner
Brothers this week in Los Angeles where
they said well because it was and
they're doing the
than men and they said to me so is the
Thin Man gonna be more like Chicago or
more like Pirates well there you go it's
like so cliche la you can't believe the
things that come out of their mouths I
said it's gonna be more like geisha I
said and then of course and I say the
same thing that you say is the reason
I'm attracted to this piece is cuz it's
different you know it's a film noir it's
a comedy you know it's a romance too
between these characters there'll be
some musical sequences in it too but
because it's in a club and so forth but
you know I was excited about that
because I love that era I love that
genre I haven't seen a movie like that I
came and think of a movie which is why I
wanted to do it then you know like what
movie is it like I don't yeah I don't
know just I can't think of a movie
except for the Thin Man 1934 so that's
why it excites me hi my name is Becca
thanks again for coming to talk to us um
New York City I'm wondering if you could
talk a bit about there are so many parts
of the film Direction process that are
so different from the theater you have
to deal with filming stunts using camera
angles editing since you came from a
theatre background what was your process
of learning those things picking up on
them on the job it's a good question I
did and here's that here's here's
another embarrassing moment for my first
time ever working on film I never forget
as long as I live I was choreographing
in that same Angela Lansbury that was my
college you know I was so lucky to have
that to make big mistakes and I was I
was standing in the in I was trying to
see what it was going to be like the the
scene and so I went like this
and this big old grip came over to me
and hit me and said
and I thought oh my god I'm so bad so
embarrassing but that's how you learn
you know I you learn on the job I
learned on the job I still learn every
time I do something I learned more about
felt more and more about film hi my name
is Denae and I'm a student here in the
School of Drama and my question is being
in LA and well any industry money making
is such a big part of it so how do you
sort of keep your integrity of either
your vision or picking a big-name actor
over someone that you really think is
right for the part and is trained or any
any type of those issues such a good
question because it's the constant
struggle you know it's like it's it's
commerce versus art and it's just that
salt will always be there it's something
you always deal with and I just try and
you know I know what the bottom line is
and what I can't do and I was I was very
lucky because my first film won an Oscar
for Best Picture which is insane
and all of a sudden I had final cut
which is what you get when you get that
you know and so I was in this incredibly
envious position where I could you know
make those kind of decisions so I I've
had I've been lucky in that way I
haven't had to you know do I don't know
Porky's five or something like that
where I had to you know you have to hire
a blank blank blank kind of thing I've
been very lucky to really I mean I'm
aware of they'll say you know it'd be
great to have a star in this part or
that kind of thing and I and I've and
I've you know I've I've fought them on
on choices you know for sure I remember
I thought when I did Annie and I done
nothing they wanted to cast ginger spice
okay
from the Spice Girls not play Annie but
to play
although she had to hair mm-hmm but to
play Lily st. Regis and I wanted Kristin
Chenoweth and they didn't who the hell
she was and Kristin had just won a Tony
for Charlie your Good Man Charlie Brown
and I knew she would be great and I knew
she was great and unless she hadn't done
what she'd done
and so I I said now and I thought and I
know what they were gonna say well
that's you know and I said no I know I
mean you do it in a nice way and you you
can you have you have you at you and you
audition ginger spice and you you go
through it you have to you can't sort of
say you're an idiot you can ever say
you're in it even though you're thinking
you're an idiot he doesn't say oh okay
that's an interesting idea and there and
then you sit down and you meet with them
and you and you and and then you should
try and show them and you put them on
tape next to each other and say this is
better a number of years ago you could
go and see in antonioni film or you'd
see the new Zeffirelli or you'd see the
new vert of Lucci you'd see the new
Renoir or whatever it was what do you go
to now what what challenges you or
inspires you what do you look forward to
soon you know this is this is the truth
TCM i watch TCM i watch old movies they
inspire me more than new movies right
for me personally I find them more
inspiring I think they're this the
stories are so much stronger in so many
ways performances in many ways I mean of
course there are great movies that you
love now that and there are a few great
directors that I really love
Woody Allen being one of them still to
this day but I look to I look to the
films that you know that I think had you
know the best yeah it's the best for me
we're about at the end of our time do we
have one final question Rob I was ready
for Pittsburgh oh hi oh my god some of
us know your parents they're wonderful
my sister went to the prom with his son
and I officiated at the wedding of your
other sister yes you did thank you oh my
gosh I just wanted to ask you what role
did your parents play in your in your
developing a career you know what and
this is the this this is I thank you for
asking that because I love answering
this everything everything because they
let me dream they let me be myself
they let me they didn't judge me you
know it was this incredible experience I
think it's because my father was adopted
as a child he lost his parents when he
was quite young and he was adopt as a
child and never really felt he had a
childhood so with us he was sort of like
the fourth child in a way it was a
beautiful thing and he was adopted by
the marshals I mean that's why my name's
Marshall I couldn't my his name was
Doyle very Irish but he was adopted by
the Marshalls and so I always felt and
they got married very young and they're
still incredibly vital they're here now
in Pittsburgh today because they flew
and they live in New York and they're
you know they just gave me the positive
reinforcement that I then try and give
others when I work with with others when
you have been a wonderful
you